um sink
all right oh hello there Internet I saw
a movie on Halloween and it was super
just okay it's an independent foreign
scary movie about American 20-somethings
doing an American 20-something out in
Ireland wilderness well dead end plot
devices chased them around in a
desperate attempt to creating intrigue
and suspense to make up for characters
that barely made it past their one-line
summer crackle of a shocker
it's called shrooms now you're probably
thinking from the title that it's gonna
be some horror movie about mushroom men
that come to life and recall arias
vaguely poetic murder on a bunch of
teenagers having sex in the woods and
you would be wrong
because that would be awesome instead
it's about the other strings the magic
ones so these barely legals this blonde
Catholic one with the overbearing father
being our protagonist have flown from
America to Ireland to take advantage of
the tax incentives offered by government
film development funds and to have a
shroom trip out in the forest with an
affable Irishman the first mistake they
make is flying to Ireland instead of
walking over to the dorms of their local
university but if they did that then the
movie would be called I had a messed up
party with a bunch of friends who I
realize now are kind of [ __ ] why do
I hang out with them again and while
that movie would also be super just okay
it would probably be even less scary as
they're driving down the road we learned
that they were willing to pay $800 each
travel halfway across the world just to
get high but not one of them was willing
to do even remedial reading about the
Troggs they were planning on taking this
is convenien
it because it gives our Irishmen a
chance to explain everything to them so
that we can hear it too amazingly the
mushroom that he talks about the Liberty
Cap is a real hallucinogenic mushroom
enjoy this because it's the movies last
connection to reality we spend the next
10 minutes foreshadowing the end of the
movie there's a story about sex in
parked cars an animal is put by the car
and beaten to death we meet some scary
yokels everyone turns in their cell
phones and keys to the least responsible
person in the group and we run into a
casting problem where two of the girls
look and sound the same but we're
expected to keep them apart in our
brains even though we split an eighth in
the parking lot before we got to the
theater then have to get our popcorn and
tickets and sit through trailers and now
it's been 45 minutes and everything is
fair I feel fuzzy like someone is
rubbing you all over with a big comfy
blanket and you'd swear that this girl
was with the jock with the small penis
so why is she getting all upset that
he's touching her bum and why does she
keep teleporting from 1:10 to the other
man it'd be sweet if you could teleport
away oh I I guess they're out hunting
for mushrooms now in a forest when
Liberty caps grow in fields but then we
learned about the death's-head fungi
that will kill you but if you survive
then you get superpowers and maybe now
you're figuring that this guy isn't the
most responsible trip leader since he
let everyone wander off and is allowing
rank amateurs to identify mushrooms when
mycology is a notoriously hazardous
hobby to begin with for this
then everything gets started when one of
the boob shrooms hypnotizes blondie
giving us a scene that borders on
pornographic as she inserts the mushroom
head into her mouth and achingly slow
motion a moment that manages to be both
sapphic and phallic at the same time
also the mushroom is apparently made of
snake venom since she goes into the lucy
neurogenic convulsions almost
immediately and then she dies but it's
cool because this dude spent a summer
working as a lifeguard and he totally
knows artificial respiration and
drowning and poisoning are the same
thing right
I guess so because she gets better all
in all it doesn't matter that she just
ate a viciously deadly plant because
instead of spending the next several
days ejecting fluids from every orifice
and slipping into a coma she trips a bit
and gets a little queasy like she ate
too much candy but she's better after a
short nap oh and she gets superpowers
maybe she can kinda see the future I
guess but not really because it's just
for losing her mind while she kills
everyone because I guess she's super
high on mushrooms and that might have
been a spoiler if you phased out the
whole story about how the deadly
mushroom that the Catholic girl just ate
makes Catholics go crazy and murder sex
everyone with repressed rage boners you
probably weren't paying attention though
because you were busy wondering why her
friends wouldn't drive her to a hospital
because at this point they haven't
actually done anything illegal there are
zero consequences for their actions up
to this point and you'd think that the
near poisoning of a friends would kind
of put a harsh tone on a trip anyway but
it's hard to care about these characters
when they don't even care about each
other then why are they friends again
the start of the second act is basically
where the movie falls apart with
character spending long periods
time walking aimlessly looking for one
thing or another before blondie goes
into vision mode imagine seeing someone
kill each of your friends in the future
just to shortly thereafter find that
person several minutes dead there's an
amusing scene with a talking Cal and
some violent penis removal that is
somewhat interesting but everything else
just lazily rolls on to the screen and
then off let's face it you went to see a
movie called shrooms with the tagline
prepared to get wasted the people who
made the movie have no delusions that
you are sober so they gave you lots of
meaningless time to get your brain back
on track for the next plot point they
also need your mind to wander so that
the big reveal at the end totally blows
it away but at the same time I don't
know if that's true because it also
seems to assume that you don't know
anything about drugs and won't question
how people who are apparently on a drug
trip that last 4 to 12 hours or
generally coherent focused and well
coordinated beyond that the setup is
stupid even for a slasher film because
they're trying to make it a slasher
whodunit where the killer is the nice
repressed blonde Catholic girl so they
have to give absolutely everyone motive
and opportunity to kill everyone else on
top of introducing menacing hillbillies
it's like wait why are these people leaf
and Friends they don't seem to have
enough in common for the normal slasher
setup of drunk sex at a cabin in the
woods on a long weekend so why did they
all fly to Ireland together
but hey a couple of the trip sequences
are kind of neat and overall the
cinematography is pretty I give it a 1
out of 1 for drugs and a 0 out of 2 for
robots for a total of 1 out of 3 needs
more robots